EVGENY GUSEV: Now, something
completely different.
5 minutes of-- but first,
let me introduce myself.
Hi, my name is Evgeny, and
I'm from [INAUDIBLE] of Wrike.
What is Wrike?
Wrike is a project
management solution
which helps you to
be more productive.
We have a lot of cool features,
such as dashboards, task lists,
views, many more.
I don't know what
[INAUDIBLE] stables.
What helps us to
be more productive?
It's Dart.
We use it for about
three years now,
and our team has grown
up to 50 plus Dart
developers, which is a lot.
And we wrote a lot of Dart code,
nearly 700,000 lines of code,
including UI components.
So Wrike loves Dart.
But today, I would like to talk
about one specific framework.
It's Angular.
Oh, sorry, wrong
kind of Angular.
That kind of Angular.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
And the main question is, is
Angular that [INAUDIBLE] number
one in the world?
No.
So this is AngularDart--
5 Minutes of No.
Is it the fastest
framework in the world?
No.
Just imagine-- you're playing
with your small, lovely to-do
list.
Everything think is
fast and smooth--
and your Chrome is blinking.
Everything is fast and
smooth, but then comes
the change detection, and
punch you right in the face.
What can you do with that?
Use onpush, always.
Use mutable data structures such
as BuiltLis and built values.
And try to avoid zones because
every time you hit the zone,
somewhere, a kitty hurts
from the change detection.
Is it the smallest
framework in the world?
No.
Just imagine you're playing with
your small, lovely Hello World.
Everything is fast and
smooth, and your template,
just a few world--
Hello Worlds-- Hello World.
You compile, wait
for just 30 seconds,
and then comes the
Angular compiler
and punch you right in the face
with 200 kilobytes of code.
Your to-do list is almost
one megabyte of code.
And your big application,
such as Wrike,
is 14 megabytes of code.
[APPLAUSE]
What can you do with that?
On set reserve whitespace
until Angular 5 release.
Keep calm and update
because with every version,
Angular produces more
compact and fast code.
And use deferred at closing.
It's help you not
to ship your codes
in one big chunk, of course.
Is it the most convenient
framework in the world?
Well, I would say that there are
other stars in this universe.
[EXPLOSION NOISES]
Yeah, that's enough.
I see people in front of me
be like, what's the point?
Why you're still here?
Just to suffer?
Does it mean that
AngularDart is bad?
I would say no, God,
please, no, no, no.
What you actually want
from your web framework,
from any framework, must
simplify complex things,
must provide a layer of
abstraction, and of course,
help you to be more productive.
And Angular have this one
in all these features.
Not every one of your
team is a [INAUDIBLE]
who squeeze the juice
out of the browser.
You want that
framework will help you
and your team with every
person of your team,
just to write good code.
Yeah, maybe AngularDart
is not so fast,
but have you tried to go
to shopping with a Ferrari?
Well, I haven't, but I just
imagine that it's complicated.
And I don't think that Wrike
team can grow from this to this
if we're still using JavaScript.
And what AngularDart--
why it's good?
Because it's fast enough,
in most cases, and you can
tune it to be more fast.
It's feature rich.
If you count the number
of [INAUDIBLE] packages
for your super small library,
I bet you will surprised,
and tree shaking will
help you with the size.
And of course,
Dart type system--
well, it has some issues, yes.
But from the front
end perspective,
if it's a [KISS NOISE].
It's a masterpiece.
And it constantly improves.
With every version, AngularDart
is better, better, and better.
So I said to you that it
would be 5 Minutes of No.
I lied, because if you
ask me, is AngularDart
the framework number one in the
world to be more productive?
I would say, yes, and
I hope that next year
would be the year of
yes for the AngularDart.
Thank you.